and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn I am
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 141 today
we're going to talk about the best ways
to explain minimalism to your parents
how to explain a lot of things to your
parents because as we get older I find
that it becomes more and more difficult
to to communicate sometimes because the
dynamic changes in time we are still our
parents children quite often and thus
were often treated like children we
still feel like children even if we're
not treated like children so we're
talking about explaining minimalism
simple living intentionality and I'm
gonna talk about all my mommy and daddy
issues me too I think we're well dive
deep into some uncomfortable topics
today also how to explain minimalism and
simple living to other relatives as well
so Before we jump into the the questions
here I have this horrible ingrown hair
on my ass right now that's horrible it
really is I I'm sorry to hear that
it's the perfect metaphor though okay
here's why I woke up yesterday morning
like what the hell was going on what why
is there a pet like why is there a
literal pain in my ass and then like I
had to do a bunch of work yesterday
because we're just we've got a lot of
stuff going on right now and I was it
was work that required me sitting in a
chair and writing and reading and typing
out emails and stuff
you think sitting for so long caused no
I think I just got I just got a random
ingrown hair right and and it calls this
considerable amount of discomfort but
only when I'm seated do I get that
discomfort which was like it was this
reminder that like hey maybe you need to
get up more frequently it's like it was
throughout the day it was this constant
reminder all right get up and do some
stretches and even though you have to
work you have to sit down and I think
sometimes that the the discomfort that
we experience is more of a sign that we
need to do something different or maybe
we need to to lean into that discomfort
a little bit and I bring that up today
because we're gonna talk about some
uncomfortable topics I know when we talk
about both of our parents there's a lot
of discomfort that you and I can talk
about so I don't have any follow-up from
last episode and because I need to hop
on a flight pretty soon we should
probably go ahead and jump in the Yemen
these voicemails dive into him I've got
my my packed bag packed somewhere takt
packed bag packed now I'm dropping these
bars on him today what am i drizzling
that listen to by the way we've got
we've got Matthew Vella here he's doing
he's filming the three cameras set up
our very talented friend Matthew Vella
check him out on YouTube where we're
sending these actually were going to
talk about this three cameras set up
later but check him out on YouTube it's
Matthew D Avella on YouTube we'll put a
link to that in the show notes our first
question today is from Mariah no Maria
Maria in Joshua Tree California yeah my
name is Maria I'm from Joshua Tree
California I had a quick question for
you guys I have a very difficult
relationship with my parents they are
unsupportive of many of my lifestyle
choices and values my partner minimalism
my drive to be debt-free my hobby is
being a pet owner so often I hear Josh's
Maxim you can't change the people around
you but you can change the people around
you does this apply to my parents should
there be a finality or an ending a
discussion therapy is it even worth the
time and effort it would take to try and
fix this awful relationship that has
been going on for my entirety of my
adult life how did both of you find it
within yourselves to forgive your
parents for all their shortcomings any
help would be appreciated thank you very
much and thank you for continuing this
wonderful podcast it brings value each
and every week to my life man I I just
want to throw a disclaimer out there
this entire episode like it I can speak
only from my perspective right and I
feel like I've done a lot of things
right when it comes to difficult
relationships unsupportive relationships
but I also think I've done a lot of
stuff wrong
so I would definitely I will definitely
share that and own up to it so I guess
I'm just saying this for our listeners
because you know take what I say with a
grain of salt because it is my
perspective and and learn from the
mistakes that I have made in past toxic
relationships you can isolate that a
little bit and apply that to anything
that we ever talk yeah that's right
that's true
so specifically this man it's late cuz
there's some hard in in Moorea situation
here I mean this is a really her
question was is how how have we forgiven
our parents for all of their their
shortcomings and like for me it's it
hasn't been this process of forgiveness
it's really been this process of letting
go well let's talk about forgiving for a
second because that's important and she
ended her question with that but I think
quite often we forgive not for the other
people we forgive for us that is that's
sort of the first step in allowing us to
let go in the sort of acceptance process
yeah quite often it's about forgiving
the folks in our lives not for them they
don't sometimes they don't even need to
know that we forgave them sometimes they
can't know that we forgive them
sometimes like with my mother passing on
I'm not my father passing on they don't
know that I've forgiven them at this
point why mom did we and we could talk
about that her last year here but that
forgiving was partially so I could come
to terms with the imperfections that
we're going on the the lack of
acceptance you're saying you're saying
forgiveness is part of the healing
process I think so I mean so a few
things that I would ask Ryan is with
Maria here is have you asked for their
support I mean sometimes I think it just
comes down to have you been able to ask
for their support and then can you show
them what that support would look like
cuz you can't just say hey I need you to
support me mm-hmm
what does that mean because well support
to them it might mean one thing support
to them I mean well we're always going
to make it really difficult for you
because we think that's how you are
going to grow yeah right we're going to
hold you to our standards
set of your standards can you show them
what your standards are and why that's
important yeah for you to just say oh I
need help and then like if I just sent
you a text hey Josh I need help period
oh yeah you'd be like great I'm happy to
help you
right but in which way do you need help
exactly and so sometimes but but here's
the other thing so so what if I actually
didn't need help but I was saying that I
needed help and so the question I would
ask Maria here is do you actually need
their support or what kind of support do
you need from them maybe it's not what
you think you need maybe what you
actually need isn't what you think you
need and if you do need some support I
totally get it why do you need that
someone yeah you know it's funny man the
in a perfect world you know family it
would be it would be people who are
closer to you than your closest friends
in a perfect world and I think the idea
that I have that that's what family
should be it has made me kind of in the
same position Maria is where I feel like
I should be getting all of this support
and I feel like I should have really
awesome parents and I've gone out of my
way to support them and I've gone out of
my way to to live a meaningful life and
show them by example I should have you
know this amazing relationship with my
parents right and what what I have come
to realize is that I don't deserve
anything like I am not entitled to
anything that's the house of cards
member you are entitled to nothing when
he took away Social Security yeah but
the weird thing is then he sort of
handing out entitlements after that but
but but he the one thing he said was hey
you're not entitled to anything I think
it's a good reminder because when we
start to have this mentality of here's
what I deserve here's what I should have
yeah here's the way my life should be
going your life should not be going
anyway it becomes a slippery slope right
because I think about like ice cream
well I've had a good week this week I
deserve an ice cream no I don't deserve
an ice cream if I want to have one then
it's my decision it's probably not a
good decision but but the truth is that
I don't deserve anything other than the
fundamental rights of kindness and and
well I deserve to be left alone and not
have people you don't barge into my
house in the middle of the night or
something but but for the most part we
don't just deserve all of these extras
that we these are just expectations yeah
dude I mean we can live the most
meaningful life possible and then walk
outside and get hit by a bus right I
mean life happens to us whether we're
doing the right things or not I think
that when we do the right things and we
try to put our best foot forward and we
try to respect appreciate accept others
for their'n differences I think that
will help us to have better results but
there's nothing in life that says we
must have awesome results if we're
putting in this kind of effort right you
know it's funny you say that I we I was
walking in the office today and I almost
stepped in this giant pile of dog poop
and I barely avoided it right and I was
just having I was having a rough morning
like I was really tired and like I was
trying to get my bag pack so I'm gonna
ready take a trip right after this and
man like I think I realized right but as
I missed the dog poop I'm like oh this
morning could be way worse I could have
stepped in [ __ ]
like and and it's to me that III need to
remember that sometimes like it can
always be worse no matter what situation
you're in yeah you could add [ __ ] not
so funny if I was still gonna be work I
was thinking myself man if I stepped in
[ __ ] if I like literally stepped in
[ __ ] I'd be like oh well it could
have been worse I could've stepped in
gum yeah absolutely I know what you say
mitt well you know here's here's what I
have learned
Maria is that the word family at least
in my experience it really hasn't meant
anything what what family has meant in
in my experience with a lot of my family
members I'm trying to not like
make a blanket statement here because I
have really really awesome really
supportive family members who would go
to the ends of the earth for me the ends
of the Flat Earth I'm just joking but no
seriously like people who get wetter the
way for me so I'm not I'm not making
this a blanket statement for all my
family members but what I am saying is
that there are certain family members
who view the term family as I can treat
you however I want and you have to love
me because I'm your family member or
worse some family members have greater
expectations of me because I'm their
family member but then like the other
mean they have greater expectations like
um oh let me speak from my perspective
people treat me this way but let me let
me specifically say from my perspective
how I've done this in the past so with
my one of my sisters like she was that
she was like you know this little
innocent you know my little tiny sister
and I like just had her in this bubble
this this you know her the idea of her
was like she was in this bubble on
uncorruptible pure and then you know I
find out she's drinking and and and you
know smoking dope and doing all the
things that I was doing one out when I
was her age but but because she was my
sister like I had this very visceral
feeling of like how much she has let me
down because this thing that you this
expectation you had of this pristine
right person but there are plenty of
people who I hang out with who drink and
smoke right I still drink alcohol and
I'll still smoke and it's it's it's
something that it's not it's it's a it's
a one-way street with that attitude you
don't like smoke cigarettes no no I'm
sorry I'm sorry
yeah yeah but but yeah I guess what well
I mean I've sure I've had a cigarette in
the last 10 years or something but my
point is my point is this yeah is that I
am judging her for behavior that I've
done for behavior that that I might I
guess I guess I don't currently do it
but my
point is is that judging her for
something that I was doing at her age
and raising her standards but not my own
oh I think that is I think that is the
effect that I'm talking about that that
certain family members will have they
will raise their standards for you but
not for everyone else in their life or
themselves or I should say not family
members in their life does that make
sense yeah but so we've talked about
standards the other thing I think we
need to talk about here is his values
right and so realize that you might have
different either values or beliefs now
if you have different values from your
parents
Mariya then I think that yes it's
important to recognize that you just
have different values from them and if
they judge you judge you then their
judgment is simply a mirror that
reflects their own values that are
different from yours now that said they
might just have different beliefs from
you and the same values if they have
different beliefs that's just a
different path to get to the same place
to get to those same values and I think
you have to recognize that the only way
to recognize that though is to get
really clear on what your values are my
partner Rebecca and I will sit down
often and go over our own values to see
what's the same what's different how can
we improve how can we raise our
standards together so that we're serving
and supporting each other's values in
fact on her website Sean have you put a
link to this in the show notes podcast
Sean I'd appreciate that
it's her websites at minimal wellness
comm if you go to slash values on her
website she did this leg well together
we kind of we put this together those
values worksheet I guess you call take a
little one-page thing to help you
identify what your values are and it's
helped me and her make sure that we are
on the same page even when we value
something differently or if we have the
same value but one of us value something
more than someone else you go back to
episode 69 as well put a link to that in
the show notes too we did an entire
episode on values and getting clear on
what your values are because it isn't
until you're clear on that until you
know what they are that you can figure
out how you raise your standards
appropriately otherwise you're just sort
of walking around blindly searching and
you're constantly trying to and this
sounds like what what's happening here
to live up to someone else's
expectations someone else's values now
you and I did this a lot in our 20s
right and I think works that's
especially true with people we've looked
up to our entire lives our parents where
they try to instill their values in us
and quite often that can be a good thing
if we're provided with the right
template but they also instill their
beliefs in us and those aren't
necessarily our beliefs and quite often
they instill their their desires of
their preferences in us I think about
Serena Williams Venus and Serena
Williams their their father I think we
had been playing tennis when they were
three years old yeah and I mean
thankfully that worked out with them but
think about how many other parents are
like forcing their kids to play the
sport that they succeeded at or maybe
didn't succeed to succeed at yeah yeah
because that's their their desire isn't
actually your desire yeah man you know
Maria if if you have gone out of your
way if she has gone out of her way to to
ask for her parents support mm-hm and
she has you know kind of clearly said
here's the support I need here's the
actions that I am I'm asking if you're
willing to do and they are still in
constant opposition of her living a
meaningful life I mean in my case with
with my dad for example it's a very
similar situation to Maria's I
constantly have opposition from him when
it comes to the life that I live and
every time I spoke to him it was it was
a reminder of how I'm letting him down
it was a reminder of how he doesn't
agree with my lifestyle and it was a
reminder of how him and I will never
have this amazing relationship that I
really really want and part of that has
to do with some fundamental beliefs that
he has with respect to religion sure
that are definitely different from your
own beliefs yeah and and you know
ultimately I don't believe the same
things that he believes right and I
don't follow the same organization that
he's follows and because of that he has
created
division in our relationship he did this
a year ago two years ago where he called
me up and he's like hey son you know I
was just talking to Marilyn might that's
my stepmom and you know she pointed out
to me how I'm not gonna go into details
with dogmatix and stuff but ultimately
she pointed out to me how we shouldn't
even be having dinner with you
we shouldn't be even having having a
meal with you yeah and if you need if
you need in something from me or if you
have an emergency please reach out to me
I'm here for you
but other than that don't talk to me so
um for four years I was for the last
year too I was living in this limbo like
on the fence of is my dad gonna cut me
off altogether or is he ever going to
like treat me like you know like this
relationship like it's a normal
father-son relationship and ultimately a
relationship that you want right and
ultimately he's not he he is he is
basically using our relationship as
leverage to get me to to do exactly what
he wants and you know whether he's
coming from a good place or not I think
you know he can look in the mirror and
say oh I'm coming from a good place but
he's not considering me at all in that
situation so in this situation you know
a few weeks ago I called I called him up
I actually wrote him an email and I just
said hey look man I really really don't
like the way that you're treating me
mm-hmm and I have tried for a long time
to - you know flatten this relationship
out and like you know get it nice and
smooth and you are constantly reminding
me how we're never gonna have the
relationship that I really want so I
have to have a funeral for this
relationship I have to you know
literally accept the fact that my dad
and I will never ever ever have that
father-son relationship that I so so
deeply desire
I still have hope that maybe one day who
you know maybe he's like he has amnesia
or something and he'll hit his head and
like you know come to a senses I don't
you don't have that expectation but I do
not have that expectation so I still I
still do hold on to a little bit of hope
don't get me wrong but you know
ultimately I had to cut off all
communication with my father because any
time I communicated with him it was it
was literally direct opposition to me
living a meaningful life and I think
when it comes down to people in our life
who are in constant opposition even if
it's half the time half opposition you
know you have the the the ability to say
hey you know what you are constantly not
supporting me in fact you're doing the
opposite of supporting me you're trying
to tear me down and I really need you to
not tear me down and if they continue to
to tear you down then there's got to be
a certain something has to give right
yeah so for me yeah like I have I have
decided to stop the the the stop being
in limbo I have taken myself out of
limbo with this relationship and I've
had a funeral for what I know is
probably not ever going to happen I
think that's a great way to put it I
mean because you you also did the work
you cuz it's not just explaining the
what like here are my values your
explain you've also done the work to
explain why these are your values and so
for Maria the thing that she needs to
also understand is she can say well
being debt free is one of my values but
if your parents don't understand why
that is a value or or living a a simple
life is one of your values if you just
say the what that's that's the start
that's the first step but you gotta
explain the why I know you and I know
your father really well and I know
you've gone through the work of
explaining know why and also how it has
made you a better person for simplifying
your life and and walking away from from
your dogmatic years of youth and and how
that philosophy that Dogma was no longer
serving you in fact it was an impediment
toward the meaningful life that you
wanted to live now with many people it's
they don't have to take it as far as
having a funeral for the ideal
relationship they hope they have
but I think it's important to know and
I'm glad you shared that because it's it
is an option because sometimes the best
way that you can love somebody is from a
distance yeah and it doesn't mean you
know you don't love your father anymore
it just means this is fighting arguing
and constantly bickering back and forth
with him was not the best way to love
him no and I'll tell you what man he
even after I send that email he sent me
like a two liner email back basically
kind of playing the victim role and it
just makes me really angry yes when it's
I feel like he's doing it to himself
right I mean he is stuck in his own head
with his own beliefs and his own
dogmatix that is basically putting our
relationship in opposition to his what
he needs to live a meaningful life right
the thing is is when he sent that the
two lines back I got really really angry
and I responded back with just some
really visceral nasty stuff and it's not
like a custom out or anything but it was
just you know pretty it was kind of this
like last I felt like it was this
last-ditch effort to try and shake him
and wake him up and I think you know
when I look back at those times where
I've had these explosive fits of rage
it's usually because I don't see any
other Avenue and I guess I'm only
sharing this because I do not feel any
better for sending that that you know
visceral email back to him so I guess my
one piece of advice for sure from R is
do not express your anger to your
parents take the high ground yeah
because I really wish I would have done
that with him it is it's just
unfortunate that like that has to be my
last conversation with him this is me is
me right is me kind of you know going on
a rant and just expressing this anger
that I have yeah yeah so learn from your
regret yeah learn from my regret and
don't do that but you know the other
thing I'll say to having a funeral for
this relationship it has helped me over
the last so that happened two weeks ago
maybe three weeks ago yeah
and it's the last month still yeah it's
still very hard right yes and it hurts
very much but having the funeral for
that relationship and cutting off
communication it has allowed me to start
to move forward and every time I get
this sinking feeling of oh poor me I
don't have a good relationship with my
father I can I can you know I well two
things that I think to myself hey I
think about all the awesome
relationships I do have in my life but
the other thing too is there is closure
there like there is closure for me to
sit there and say you know what Ryan yes
I guess I can see his perspective I can
I can understand where he's coming from
but I do not respect the divisive
mnestheus
and I don't understand why he chooses to
do that but I never will understand
right and it's almost like I've given
myself permission to not understand why
he acts the way he acts mmm but now give
yourself the closure as opposed to
waiting for the closure
yeah and then on top of that too it's
like because I had that figurative
funeral for that relationship like it's
it's almost like this like I'm starting
to heal over this really crappy toxic
relationship yeah you're in this process
of lamenting that right now and and and
this is a lament and and and that's what
you're experiencing and it's not a
pleasant feeling but what comes out of
it will be more pleasant than the
constant back and forth yeah it will the
questioning yet the back-and-forth is
unbelievably frustrating toxic it's so
bad dude but then just that again
sitting in limbo wondering if you know
having that hope that this relationship
will one day be and like expecting it
like a piece of me expecting it to
happen yeah like that is that's more
torture than just accepting the fact
that this relationship is dead so really
Maria answered her own question you were
spending a lot of time trying to change
the people around you mm-hmm but you
realize like now I've got to change the
people around me meaning surrounding
myself with the P
who are supportive now people were
placating you I don't placate no didn't
we challenge each other but in a way
that is supportive and kind and caring
and loving and we might disagree but I
can't tell you ever when you and I have
gone back and forth and done something
toxic through to each other and if we
did we'd find a way to repair that
really mmm it's it's just it's
unfortunate man because I know there are
people who are listening to this right
now and they think a family and they've
got an amazing family and you know when
I think of like the of like the the most
oh what's the word I'm looking for like
the most cliche version of like a family
who's like super strong tight-knit is
would be like the Mafia like I mean that
is like that is a super tight-knit
family right yeah
and it's obviously I'm not encouraging
people to behave like the Mafia but that
level of dedication I see it in Hispanic
culture a lot to where family actually
means something and family they look at
as oh that's my family I need to be
kinder to them I need to be more
supportive to them I need to forgive
them more than anyone else in my life
who isn't family because family they
actually hold up and in an ideal world
that's what that's what family is right
but unfortunately in my experience
especially with my parents
that has never been the case well I and
I could do one or two things dude I
could sit here and look in the mirror
and I could say oh poor me oh why don't
I have a good family oh my my mom if it
wasn't for her this and if my dad didn't
do that and then this would happen I
could sit there and be depressed and you
could be the victim or I can accept the
fact that life really doesn't have any
specific order that it has to be in
mm-hm and to really understand that my
expectations
shape my mood that's pithy put that in
the show notes podcast Shawn I think
what you did is I'm noticing here you
shifted from having the victim mentality
sort of accidentally or you you you you
were playing the victim role because you
had been victimized your father was
victimizing you and
you what you've turned into now is you
you by having this closure you've turned
that victim role into a Victoire role
role and now now you are being
victorious it with your other
relationships and some podcast Jean and
I were talking about last week is I
think quite often the thing you're
talking about with with family is we
mistake blood relatives for family hmm
and I mean you're closer to me than any
of my blood family members I have five
half siblings whom I barely know because
my father had them in his first marriage
and I've met all of them a couple times
and ever since we were all like on this
Today Show and stuff I've had at least
one of them reach out to me for money
but I I can tell you that that I mean
there might be my technical family but
like my real family is more of a
metaphorical thing with the people who
I've chosen to surround myself with who
are supportive I look at people like you
and backs and Sean and Matt over here
I'm much closer with you all than I am
with someone just because we happen to
you know you shoot out of the same yes I
love the same there we go
dude you know it's I find myself like
recording this podcast and talking with
you like I feel I have not felt this
stilted in a long time and it's because
it's hard to look at your family member
and say you know what I can't talk to
you anymore right it's hard to look at a
family member and say this relationship
is so toxic in my life that I have to
cut you out there's nothing easy about
that right and it almost sounds to me
like I saying it out loud it sounds
insensitive to to even recommend that
but but I do know from my own experience
that yes sometimes we have to look at
our blood relatives and and make make
really hard choices sometimes I don't
think it's insensitive and I'll tell you
why I think it scary
I'm glad you say that and here
why I think it's caring because you're
finally caring for yourself here and and
you're protecting yourself because
here's the problem if you're literally
going out and getting beat up every day
like physically beat up you're gonna
avoid whatever behavior like I'm not
gonna walk in that neighborhood anymore
I got beat up three days in a row we're
gonna stop doing that but what's
happening is you were being beat up
psychologically consistently and and
allowing it to happen over and over and
eventually I'm not blaming you as the
victim but eventually you realize like
oh I shouldn't travel in this
neighborhood anymore I have another
option and for you that neighborhood
that you were getting beat up in
psychologically was this particular
relationship and you tried to reason
with the with your captors and and say
hey guys that we shouldn't fight and
here's why we shouldn't fight you you
worked through it it wasn't just like
well I'm terrified so I'm going to avoid
everything no you actually went in there
and did the work and the best way to
care for yourself because you can't
provide for anyone else if you're being
beat up all the time you're not the best
version of yourself I think it's it's
the absolute most caring thing you can
do for the people you love I'll tell you
man like over the last so over these
last two or three weeks I had this one
like thought where I was like oh I wish
I could have said this to my dad before
I before I ended our relationship I wish
I coulda said this one thing so I
actually thought okay I'm gonna like do
a voice recorded thing and I'm gonna
email this to him
just so I can get this one last thought
out but as I was like recording this
voice memo for him mm-hmm I just
realized like there's nothing I can say
more that's going to really that's
really going to change his mind so I'm
bringing this up for for the reason that
if you end a relationship and the
relationship yeah do not do this because
I said do this with my ex-girlfriends oh
we're broken up no we're not we're
broken up no we're not we're broken up
no we're not that is that's just a
recipe for more discontent sure but the
other thing too is by not reaching back
outs and that actually like I woke up
the next day and I felt good
and it's I am healing and I am feeling
better I know it again I know it sounds
crazy to like cut off communication with
my dad but it truly has helped me move
forward and Maria maybe you don't have
to be that maybe maybe
Maria is listening to this and she's
like oh you know what I haven't
approached my parents in this way oh I
didn't ask my parents for support oh I
didn't go out of my way to support my to
support my parents because Maria before
you cut off any relationship with either
your parents you've got to do those
things you got to make sure that you're
adding as much value to their life as
possible that you're supporting them as
much as possible because then when you
ask for support they're gonna be willing
to give it back to you and then showing
them how they can I hope that's the case
I hope that she is coming up with a new
approach to to dealing with her parents
if she has done all that then yeah it
might be time to to start distancing
yourself from from that relationship I'm
thinking about the closure that you got
here this was a self-imposed closure and
I think that's a very good thing I was
checking my email this morning and um I
got the inbox zero because I have OCD
and so I is this weird image pops off
and it says you have no messages have a
nice day
and I realize like I don't have to wait
and it was just weird like sort of light
bulb went off of my head hey Josh you
don't have to wait until you're at inbox
zero and so every everything on your
to-do list is checked off so to speak
your today list then you don't have to
wait till everything is done before you
can have a nice day
you can have a nice day and then happily
accomplish these things as they come
along and of course prioritize them
accordingly but realizing that you're
never going to get to everything in your
life you're never it's never going to be
perfect and now might be the time for
closure
whether that's as something as simple as
closing the browser window and walking
away from that realize okay it wasn't
finished
but I've provided some closure or
something really difficult where there's
a relationship maybe it's someone you've
been dating maybe it's a loved one
maybe it's a family member maybe it's a
parent and there could be time for
closure with that as well well I'd love
to send you a copy Maria of our book
minimalism live a meaningful life we we
wrote about the five different values
that Ryan and I came up with and one of
those values is relationships there's an
entire chapter in this book on
relationships Oh podcast Sean if you
could reach out to her send her a copy
of the audiobook if she wants the
audiobook if you like our podcast you'll
definitely like the audiobook version or
if you want the book book version we
could send you that or the eBook version
we hope you enjoy it
our next question is from Riley in st.
Louis my name is Riley Brown I am 20
years old and I live in st. Louis
Missouri congratulations on your 100th
episode and I hope you come visit my
town again my question for you is how
can I better shine light on my
essentialist lifestyle as I'm getting
older my family is growing more and more
non supportive of the changes I choose
to make with who I am everything from
items been removed to Matt for my life
too I will react to situations to
constantly refuting my mission in life I
feel like they undermined and deny Who I
am because they want me to become as
they are now how can I help them see
that I am my own person pushing my own
path and only wish to be accepted thank
you very much had a great day
so Ryan I was reminded of two essays
that are on our website that we wrote
one of them together and I wrote this
one recently about unsolicited discharge
now I'm not sure if this is exactly what
Riley is getting I sort of wrote this
about criticism but he's certainly
getting some criticism before I read a
little bit of this though she said
something that was fascinating to me she
said how do i shine a light on my
minimalist lifestyle and I think
something is important to realize there
there's light above us right so yeah
spotlight almost right now there's a
thing there's a good and bad side of
shining a light on something because
because you can see my dry skin in the
corner of
the temples here and it brings out all
the falls right yeah let you have that
scar on your forehead and I can
definitely see that scar on your
forehead right now I think it makes you
more beautiful thank you
now the but they call me Frankenstein in
grade school so so one thing to think
about here if you're trying to shine the
light just keep in mind that you're also
going to illuminate the flaws now the
good thing is you'll actually see what
to improve as well and by shining the
light so you and I we have written a lot
about our own lives we've talked about
our own lives Allah we've done videos
and documentary about our own lives our
lives are out there we've signed the
light on our lives
yeah and it's helped me really
understand and come to terms but also
it's really difficult that last little
segment a podcast Shawn's tearing up in
the corner over there where you're
talking about your relationship with
your father I think it's gonna help a
lot of people but shining the light on
that is also really difficult and it's
hard to talk about and quite often we
don't want to confront these issues for
real we think we do but realize that if
you're going into battle with some of
these issues it's actually going to be a
battle now and it's in terms of of
dealing with their undermining and
they're not being supportive and you
want to help them understand I thought
about this essay unsolicited discharge
or put a link to in the show notes but
it just goes a little something like
this it's really sure last week Ryan and
I filmed a living room conversation on
our YouTube channel about dealing with
criticism well I agree with everything
we said I'd like to add a few words
there is a significant difference
between feedback and criticism we must
seek feedback from trusted people
because it makes our work and our life
better right you know feedback in fact
yesterday we were in the process of
hiring a filmmaker for the minimalists
and what we did is we we got in a room
we got with the 19 different finalists
we were watching their their their
videos their submissions their reels but
then we we narrowed it down to a top
seven and we sent the top seven
our trusted friends we wanted feedback
from people like mad and and I send it
to Bex and and yeah yeah exactly and so
we got and Jess Jessica provided
feedback and and so we got feedback from
all of these these different people
because feedback helps us understand
what we're missing gives us a clean pair
of eyes and it's important it's always
they're not gonna agree with us but
that's a good thing right
yeah man it well criticism is so
important man it's so important here's
the thing I say feedbacks important I
like to die I I know it sounds like
semantics but I like to differentiate
for me feedback provides the problem
with the solution most criticism when I
think about like just this horrible
criticism it just highlights the problem
and they're like oh look at that scar on
his forehead yeah YouTube comment what's
here let's see that's where I
differentiate that's not that's not
criticism that is discharge exactly so
so for me when I say criticism is
important I think criticism can be part
of feedback I don't think they're you
know uh interchangeable words but I
think criticism is is a piece of that
I think criticism is important because
none of us are perfect and any of us who
walk around and think that we have it
figured out 100% well then that that
person's an idiot yeah and for me to not
take for me to not look at criticism
even going back to the the relationship
with my dad the criticism he would give
me I would you know try to subjectively
look at as best as I could in and I can
look at some of this criticism and it
does one or two things for me it either
makes me say oh you know what they have
a point I should XY and Z or it makes me
look at myself and say oh you know what
no I'm really really secure with who I
am and the way that I'm living my life
and I don't agree where where their
perspective is coming from with that
criticism so it strengthens who it
either helps me be a better person or it
will strengthen who who I already am
with with criticism yeah when it comes
to discharge when it comes to
unsolicited discharge that stuff I can
easily look at and and just kind of
compartmentalize it and be like oh like
that person is a troll well especially
anything online because like people they
behave totally different online yes
there are different people online than
they are in real life and so yeah
absolutely the different the different
formats that we go through so so when
you talk about this discharge the thing
that I think about is you say it's easy
for you to compartmentalize it I think
for most people and for us until we you
and I've been criticized so frequently
so much it's like up to and including
death threats it hurt yeah it hurt up
until about midway through 2014 I
finally started to like just be able to
compartmentalize it like what and that's
because I think we developed some some
calluses along the way yeah but but when
I talk about seeking feedback from trust
of people and then avoiding criticism
from they say errs because it it really
I think it clutters our lives if we're
just getting the that discharge right
yeah and so so here's the thing I said
in the essay whenever you create
something meaningful you will be
critiqued and I would say oh yeah -
Riley whenever you do something
meaningful if you're simplifying your
life and you find meaning that if you're
getting rid of debt if you're trying to
make some sort of change you were going
to be critiqued there's no doubt about
whatever you stand for something and
people in your life are not standing for
the same thing they want to point out
how you're really not standing for that
I'm not standing for that and you're
really not standing for it either and
here's why you're not a real minimalist
you own underwear or whatever right in
fact I've got some examples here that I
pulled these from our youtube comments
recently and so I've what I said is no
matter how close to perfect your
creation is or no matter how close to
perfect your life is right no matter how
close the perfect it is you will be
judged and so here are some some recent
comments I know and I'll tell you what I
did with them in a second the lighting
in your on your podcast looks creepy
ladies this video is stupid and they
spelled stupid st oh oh PID yeah that's
so funny and someone actually commented
don't
quit your day job and so but you know
what though if we met those three people
in person they wouldn't dare say that to
our face right I I agree with and that's
that to me that's how I can court
mentalize it it's because well just with
the example the person who spelled
stupid sto Oh PID they obviously don't
even take their own comment seriously
exactly but but here's the thing I and I
think that translates to Riley's
question here I think when we get so
comfortable with someone sometimes we
accidentally say some of these things
that are hurtful and we don't realize
that they're hurtful they're just flip
it these are really flippant comments
yeah and we're really close to someone
like parents or close family members
sometimes we accidentally say things
that's the exception your family they
will say that stuff to you right it's
your face yeah but yeah which it does
hurt and so that's why I this this this
stood out with me and Riley so here's
what I'll say to Riley from the essay
most criticism is merely an unsolicited
discharge of personal preference and
because you didn't ask for it
you aren't required to respond you know
I didn't respond to these people know
this video isn't stupid but no the
lighting see what we're trying to do it
I don't care right I don't have a day
job should I get one yeah what a job do
you recommend I get and so so so you
aren't required to respond in fact it's
best not to clap back instead click
delete or mute or block and move on to
the next creation so that's exactly what
I did with with these I I block these
people I'll never see their comments
ever again and here's the thing I think
you may not be able to block them but
you can delete or mute and sometimes
that requires the leverage you have with
your parents with your family members is
creating some distance from them if
they're behaving in a way that is
unsupportive then you don't have to
accept that you can walk away it doesn't
mean it doesn't mean you go to the
extreme right away if well I've had a
funeral for oh you said one bad thing
about me this relationship is dead yeah
it's not about that it's about Oh
pointing out hey you know what you just
said right there I feel like that's
really not supportive yeah and I'd
appreciate if you would support me
because I care about you and I think you
care about me just to go back to your
point of because yeah you're not gonna
end a relationship over one criticism or
one negative interaction and there
really isn't a number of how many
interactions you have to have before you
end a relationship but it just made me
think the the when I know to end a
relationship is when I feel tormented
when I feel like I've done everything I
can to save a relationship I still feel
tormented and I have been putting in
that us box and I've been putting in
that us box and and and the other person
has not put anything in that us box and
if anything they've been taking from it
like that is where I think is where you
end the relationship
Riley you are not at this point you're
20 years old yeah you are you've got a
so funny man because when I was 20 I
would say the same stuff like man I'm
getting older and like people just you
know 37 year olds like me would laugh at
laugh at myself and be like haha you
think you're getting older you're 20
years old but so so you know I'm not I'm
not undermining the fact that Riley is
getting older but Riley you're super
young and I'll tell you it took my mom
about five years before she finally came
around and she is so supportive now and
I'd never thought it was gonna happen
the hope was there but the expectation
of getting a hundred percent support
from my mom it was it was not there now
luckily that relationship did come full
circle and you know I've told the story
before I'll tell it again real quick but
like the moment I realize like oh my god
like my mom she accepts me and she is
supporting me it's when she was visiting
Mariah and I am Montana and it was the
first time she had ever come out there
Mariah and I had just moved into a new
place I picked her up from the airport
bring her back to my house she opens up
her suitcase and the first thing she
pulls out is like this like a vase and
some candles and some other stuff and
she's like hey I got you a present and
like in my head I'm like all right Ryan
don't be a jerk
don't project my own insecurities about
having things that I don't need yeah so
I didn't say anything I just you know
let her talk and she was like here are
some things I love you I'm proud
I am really proud of the relationship
you've built with Mariah this is a
beautiful place and I just wanted to
show you my appreciation
if this doesn't fit in your life then
please go find a good home for it please
give it away to someone that who is
gonna use it and it was in that moment I
was like oh my god like breakthrough
yeah it took five years yeah
to get that breakthrough so Riley um so
that on the other on the other side of
the spectrum with my mom I showed
support went way out of my way to
appreciate her to accept her to love her
to respect her I did everything I could
and it paid off after five years so
Riley do the same thing with your
parents show them support show them love
show them respect go out of your way to
have these conversations with them about
how you need respect see when when we
when when any of us demand respect
we first must ask the question have we
shown respect right and if if that is
not the case then you must show respect
before you gain respect can't demand or
connect that's not how respect works
it's not how it works and her question
was can you how can how can I help them
understand that I want to be accepted
and that reminded me of this other essay
that we wrote called understanding
others I'm certainly not gonna read this
whole thing because it's a long one but
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
but there's this acronym in there ta ra
that you've heard us talk about before
and it's it's really the path to our
understanding other people and so all in
respects one of those but Riley if you
want them to accept you that is like
that's after the first step its
tolerance first first you have to find a
way they can tolerate your lifestyle so
are they doing that are you tolerating
them as well and then it gets toward
acceptance and we we talk about the
steps on sort of getting past tolerance
because it starts there but tolerance is
a really weak virtue and if you just
tolerate someone imagine if you're
you're living with Mariah I mean you
live with Mariah now but you all just
tolerated each other God that would be a
miserable existence but it is necessary
to have the tolerance first before you
can get to the acceptance of well she's
different she has her own preferences
her own desires her own interests and
then beyond that a huge leap to the
third step is respect the AR
Tara you know it's good well and the
last one is appreciation and that is the
huge leap eventually I think you can get
to a point Riley where you appreciate
them for who they are warts and all
realizing that their life is different
from yours yeah and that's okay in fact
that's what makes life beautiful or all
these differences because what what's
the alternative they were all exactly
the same yeah well then there's nothing
to appreciate anyway yeah I was just
gonna say when it comes to that
appreciation piece of it man it's not
like so with Mariah as an example late
yeah she has more things than I than I
have I don't know the number of things I
just know that there are a lot of things
around the house I'm like oh like that's
not mine that's more ice and it's not
that I appreciate the fact that she
collects more things but what I do
appreciate is the love the kindness the
respect that Mariah shows this
relationship and I also appreciate
everything she does for our relationship
I mean the the way that um she's just
like your stereo typical loves to cook
and loves to take care of the house and
loves to like just really create a
beautiful environment for us to live in
you have to take care of the relation
she does and I appreciate that so much
that for me to look at her stuff and say
you know what I know that you got more
stuff than me but it's cool I love you
so much
and like everything you do for this
relationship I appreciate so much if it
if it if it helps her if it shows her
the appreciation by me letting go of my
own insecurities and my own
idiosyncrasies for her for her I want to
say her well-being but it's more than
her well-being but her preferences yeah
I'm sure Matt does this with with
Natalie which by the way Matt just got
engaged
oh my god yeah Congrats man Thalia
that's right but and he I mean with
Natalie I mean I know she's definitely
not him in unless you did a video on
your YouTube channel about living with
your non minimalist girlfriend your non
minimalist fiance you ought to like
update the title right you just go in
like
do voiceovers like to inject the word
fiancee but I mean she showed up to
dodge ball last week I could tell she
was probably wearing a brand-new outfit
the said USA because it was a 4th of
July no I could tell like like Matt
would never show up wearing the USA tank
top or whatever put like it instead of
pretty and the cool thing is like I
actually saw you appreciated that like
you've got this little Australian woman
who shows up at our dodgeball league
like being the most American fourth of
July person there and it was pretty
great so you're able to appreciate these
idiosyncrasies in a way when you step
back from yourself and realize hey I'm
not solipsistic I'm not the center of
the universe
right I can appreciate these other
things too and that's okay yeah yeah
yeah and I guess what I'm trying to get
at too is like again it's not like I
appreciate head-on I look at Mariah's
collection of things and I head on I go
you know what I've learned to appreciate
her collection of things know what what
I have learned to do is by showing her
that I accept
I accept her idiosyncrasies that is in
turn showing her how much I appreciate
the relationship you you appreciate her
as a whole even if even if you don't
like every single trinket right yeah all
right well Riley I'd love to seen you
copy of our book everything that remains
there's a there's a chapter in there
where we talk about sort of surrounding
ourselves with supportive people in that
transition from our corporate world in
the days of yesteryear into a life that
was more meaningful with more people who
were supportive so I'd love this and you
copy that either the audio book the book
book or the e-book and also if you're
willing to make a drive down to
Louisville which is not that far from
st. Louis I've actually made the drive
from Louisville to st. Louis before it's
about four hours it's about right three
and a half four hours drive really fast
two and a half hours know it but it's
it's not that long of a drive we're
gonna be in Louisville this weekend with
Chris Hogue and we're going on the
simply southern tour so Shawn when you
reach out to her give her a copy of
everything that remains but ask her if
she wants a couple tickets to the
Louisville stop we're going to be there
we're going to be in Alabama and
Tennessee as
well with Dave Ramsey's team all right
we're removing from here we'd love to
hear what you all have to say so if you
have a comment or a tip about parents or
family or understanding others then
leave us a voicemail for zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine you can
also email a voice memo right from your
phone to podcast at the minimalists comm
well air our favorite comments and tips
on a future episode and stay tuned to
the end of this week's episode for this
week's listener comments and tips Ryan
what time is it you know what time is it
you know what time is it you know what
time it is it's time for our lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media we do indeed we're on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram at the
minimalists during the lightning rounds
where Ryan and I each do our best to
answer every question with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our quotes in one place
thanks to Jessica Lynn Williams you can
find them over at minimal Maxim's calm
all right our first question is from
Taylor my parents constantly asked me to
clear their clutter for them but they
aren't willing to give up anything what
do I do well so my pet the answer to
this and maybe we could talk a little
bit about it is doing is often the
opposite of helping but think about this
for a second I mean yeah you could help
them by maybe doing it together right
but if I'm constantly doing something
for you I'm not really helping you
unless you absolutely need to help right
Ryan if you broke both of your legs and
both of your arms I'm happy to get you
food while you recover but it's like
after you've recovered I'm still spoon
feeding you like that's not helping
anyone right - yes analyzing them so I
think what is happening right now is is
Taylor is infantilizing his or her
parents I'm not sure if Taylor's a guy
or gal here but but you might just be
infantilizing you in fact enabling them
and keeping them from growing if they're
asking for help then maybe the best way
to help them is to show them how you do
it together yeah my short answer is this
helping is
helpful unless the people you're helping
don't want help
mmm and ultimately I think about I had a
situation with a family member where
they were doing a lot of drugs and
another family member was like hey I
need you to talk to so-and-so they're
having a really hard time they're hooked
on drugs and it would really mean a lot
to me if you went and tried to help him
out and I went and talked to this family
member and from the first sentence that
they said like I could tell they didn't
want help like they knew they had a
problem but they were okay with having a
problem yeah and that's the only
conversation I had with them about
trying to help them essentially because
all because ultimately trying to help
them when they don't want help was
driving me it would drive me mad it
drove me mad growing up my mother was a
really bad alcoholic most of most of my
childhood years and you know as a kid
you don't really understand why and
you're like hey if you loved me you
would stop ray and I would try to help
and I thought it was helpful to like
hide her wine or high and her beer that
was I mean it it temporarily stopped the
problem and I saw hilarious video on on
Jesus and marrow they were you know they
go over like clips there was this kid
who's trying to go his mom to stop
smoking he was a constantly sneak up on
her with a pair of scissors and just cut
the tip off of her cigarette and run
away she'd get mad and throw his stuff
out in the same thing we're kind of
having my mom except there was no
hilarity ensuing like I didn't have
anything fun like I was just like really
hurt by the whole whole thing and
realized like she sometimes she wanted
help but there were times when she
didn't and I was like I was trying to
force help on to someone you can't drag
someone kicking and screaming to success
no I mean there's always an exception to
the rule but that's not that's not a
good plan right yeah yeah and so I think
it sounds to me like there here's the
good good news though they're asking you
for help it sounds like they're asked
you to clear that maybe they're not
maybe they're saying oh we're lazy and
want you to clean
more clutter now that's the case then
you say I can't help you but if they're
saying hey can you help me say yeah I'd
be happy to help you let's the three of
us get together this Saturday at 2 p.m.
and I'll show you exactly how I'm able
to organize my stuff and I think it'll
help you out a lot so be willing to help
if they want the help but only if
they're willing to help you know the
themselves the other thing too like I
just thought with you saying that is his
parents have to contribute somehow right
hey get rid of my stuff and then I put
the burden on you to get rid of my stuff
Josh you come over to my house and then
I just push back on everything you try
to help me with so Taylor don't don't
keep spinning your wheels here won't
evil words - helping a drowning person
you might drown yourself yeah yeah tweet
that Sean all right what's a nice
question our next question is from Larry
is there a way to get aging parents to
understand the real value of possessions
that they believe have worth but are
likely worthless so they stop trying to
give away things that someone else will
simply need to throw out so yeah I have
seen plenty examples of this where
you've got like a maybe not like the the
the worst side of the spectrum hoarding
mm-hmm but you've got people who went on
to a lot of stuff a lot of antiques a
lot of trinkets a lot of things trinkets
is a good word for them and I've been to
these you know I've been to homes like
this and they're like oh you need a
blender literally like I've been this
you need a blender here's a blender and
like the blender that I get I'm like oh
thank you but it's like it's not you
know it's got weird stains on it and
it's just not a blender that I would
ever spend any money on or like just
maybe does have the feature that didn't
have the feature I need it but I
remember taking that blender was
actually a food processor taking that
food processor and then giving it away
in donating it or worse it could be
broken like hey I've got but you
actually it was personally broken but
you can get it fixed right and so
they're essentially I mean they're not
essentially they are quite literally
handing you trash yeah
and it's it it doesn't it seems
different but it's not appreciably
different from if I were to go into my
trashcan pull out the trash bag and say
hey Ryan you need this you know what I
do as a minute
when I meet these people Josh and you
can corn them and you go like this with
your finger for the people watching this
podcast shout-out to our YouTube viewers
um I take the item when I say thank you
yeah and that's it ma'am yeah because it
you know at that point like I'm not
going to I'm not gonna help them by
scoring them help them either
yeah I'm not helping them by projecting
my own insecurities at them
I am yeah I'm not gonna change them by
there's no magic sentence I could say
that's gonna make them stop hoarding
well I wrote something down here this
isn't my short answer but it echoes with
exactly what you said you don't have to
be mean to be honest and we can provide
feedback without questioning someone's
intentions and so a few short answers
here patience is paramount sometimes we
have no patience people because hey you
know what it took me personally 29 years
to get to minimalism right right now all
of a sudden I'm going to expect you to
change over the long holiday weekend or
something it doesn't work that way and
so it's about having patience the other
people so what you're displaying there
when you take that thing is you're
having patience now you can still show
them through your actions not through
well you know what this is a piece of
junk that's that's not helpful so it's
about being helpful still it's still
being kind yeah although here's what
I'll say and here's my pithy answers
most gift horses have tooth decay you
know they say don't look a gift horse in
the mouth but I think that's nonsense
I've never understood that saying what
okay the saying is don't learn so back
in that if you've got a gift horse wait
[ __ ] is a gift or a gift horse like a
horse that's been gifted to me yeah yes
okay there would be a gift like a nice
gift
okay I'm giving you thanks for a horse
so don't look it in the mouth because
because sometimes people just give you a
horse that's dying and you could tell
because they had rotting teeth if they
had man okay and so someone gave you a
gift horse first thing people do look at
the teeth is like I don't want to care
for this rotting horse if you give me a
dying horse I don't have to deal with it
so realize that if you're getting a gift
maybe it's it's not an actual gift now
that I understand what this idiom means
don't agree with it well here's a gift
here's a rotting gift uh-huh so the term
don't look a gift horse in the mouth
means just take the shut up and take the
gift that's that's why I say I don't
agree with it I say most gift horses
have 2/3 so look out for that and
realize that that my guess I'm really
saying is most gifts aren't necessarily
gifts but also junk is in the eye of the
beholder so maybe they really thought
they were giving you something really
nice and and they thought they were
being caring and and that's why you the
way you approach is okay thank you very
much have a nice day
and then you once it's your thing you
get to determine what you do with your
thing you know it's kind of if you think
about it like people who let's go with
the horse or the blender for that matter
I have a really I have a horse with
tooth decay maybe it's got three three
good years left right I give it to you
here here's here's a gift horse it's
kind of it's kind of selfish for me to
be like yeah I don't want to I don't
want to take the last three years out of
this horse you know it's it's it's it's
already dying but here Josh he can take
the last three days oh I don't want this
blender because yes I have a better
blender I have a better food processor
here's one that's slightly broken
slightly damaged so I'm gonna pawn that
off on someone else yeah so they can get
the maximum life out of it yeah that
just that seems that's a horrible saying
portable say my short answer is this
it's difficult oh wait wait
no my short answer is this you can't fix
a problem until you see the problem so
how do you get a hoarder or someone
order or you know person in your life
who really values sentimental items how
to view them differently you really
there's nothing you can do to change
their perspectives there's nothing you
can say to them what you can do is you
can live a meaningful life you can show
them by example what what it means to
live a simplified life yeah and if they
look at you and think oh wow
that person looks really happy I'm gonna
start applying some of their principles
in my life because they seem like
they're living a really happy life if
that person is looking at you and saying
oh my god how can they how can they live
without a garage full of boxes filled
with trinkets and junk I don't know how
they live their life that way
crazy I love my junk that's that and
that's their preference right and well
it goes back to what Riley was saying if
you shine a bright enough light you will
eliminate the flaws but in this case
you're shining the light on a more
meaningful life a less cluttered life a
calmer stiller life maybe that's gonna
look appealing to them instead of me
saying you need to get rid of your stuff
say wow look how calm this is all right
PS Ryan we have one PostScript question
here can you discuss the need for
financial boundaries when it comes to
grandkids how can you raise a child to
understand worth when everything is
given so we have a problem here with
grandparents I see this personally other
family members they constantly want to
give stuff to Ella because we think that
gift-giving is a love language so we're
gonna answer that on our PostScript
episode today and if you'd like to hear
our answer to that question you can
listen to this week's PostScript episode
over at the minimalists private podcast
available exclusively to our patreon
supporters that's why it's a private
podcast so if you want to support our
show and keep this podcast a hundred
percent advertisement free because
advertisements suck then head on over to
the minimalists comm slash support let
me just say this instead of you continue
to read this whole script here we use
the patreon support to pay for the
studio space yes we refuse to do
advertisements on our podcasts on our
youtube videos on our website we don't
do advertisers anywhere if you want to
read why go to the minimalists calm
slash ads we have a long essay
it's an honest conversation starter
really about what we think about
advertisements are they all inherently
bad no most of them kind of suck
right yeah especially like well the
platform like YouTube for example you
don't you really don't get to choose the
advertisements either right even if we
could choose the advertisement we still
wouldn't do it right and same Harrises
and something about this recently I
quoted him in that essay called can we
have an honest conversation about
advertisements we'll put a link to that
in the show notes but here's the thing
Ryan and I don't make any money from
this podcast from our YouTube videos
fact we spend money on this stuff so we
have to rent out the studio space we had
to build the studio space we had to pay
for
all the equipment we pay podcast Shawn
to produce a show we're hiring a
filmmaker as well
patreon almost covers half of that and
so the rest of it comes from me and Ryan
in fact the costs are about to go up
hiring the filmmaker is going to be
costly and the only way that we can
afford it is if we have enough support
from our patreon supporters so when we
ask you to support the show we're really
appreciative and we give a lot back to
our patreon supporters as well you get
every week you get a bonus episode we do
a postscript episode where we answer one
question we're gonna answer this
question about grandkids and family
members giving stuff to our kids we give
you a PostScript episode every week
there's over 60 of them out there right
now we give you access to all four
unpublish live events so if for an
example we just put out the Melbourne
event we did the Sydney event which one
are we doing next Shawn I think we're
doing is a Houston or Dallas one of them
Houston okay podcast Shawn's telling me
Houston so the next one's coming out as
Houston and so any of our live events
you could access to those also any of
our upcoming live events you get access
to tickets before they go on sale to the
general public so you get the best seats
in the house we also do a monthly
livestream video called ask the
minimalists anything so you can ask us
any question you want and we answer it
and we also let our hair down a bit on
those on those episodes I won't tell you
exactly what we talked about but
sometimes we're able to get I'll just
say a little more intimate on the it's
easy to be open when you know this is
going out to only a few thousand people
instead of rate hundreds of thousands or
millions yeah yeah so if you want to
support us head on over to the
minimalists comm slash support we really
do appreciate it shout out to our
patreon supporters you keep this podcast
100% advertisement free and here is a
snippet from this week's PostScript
episode
[Music]
if you remove all of life's friction
yeah you lose traction yeah remember
when you had your accident your your car
accident your crash of early 2014
January 2014 you're driving down i-90
and you crashed because the person next
to you had no traction yeah they'll they
had no friction because it was ice right
and they slid into you if you lose
traction you start sliding all over the
place yeah I think you do that in life
when money is just handed to you and
toys are just handed to you everything
is just handed to you don't have to work
for it and so I think the answer here is
help your kids do something help your
kids by encouraging to do difficult
things okay now it's time for our added
value portion of the shows where we each
talk about something that has added
value to our lives
recently Ryan you know I'm rarely
sentimental and it's pretty hard to get
me to tear up over anything
I was so Dennis Johnson died was that
last year two years ago long as he died
yeah oh man he you know he lived in
Idaho it was his son right yeah Jesus
son hero well he's not Jesus his son no
no he wrote Jesus yeah the novel called
Jesus son which is nothing like what it
sounds like no it's about heroin and the
main care it has nothing to do with
Christianity no the main care of his
name is [ __ ]
right yeah anyway he wrote this short
story collection called the largest of
the sea maiden and I read the first
story it was really good and then
sometimes Beck's and I were like read
aloud we were sitting out on the the
balcony over the weekend I was reading
the second short story in there I think
was called the Starlight on Idaho and
it's about is very similar to Jesus's
son there's like this guy he's in this
rehab facility
and he's writing letters to light his
and and this was like the appropriate
for this he was like writing letters to
his grandparents and parents about how
all these times he screwed up and but
then he was writing a letter to the Pope
and he was like he was coming to terms
going through his sort of 12-step
process and and you're going to a
meetings kind of thing and III have you
been to a meetings before um I have with
my mom a few times when I was a kid yeah
me too I went I went quite a bit I went
to al-anon meetings as well which is
like family members of people who were
in AAA and it just brought back this
this rush of like oh man like because he
was my mom believed very heavily about
like a lot of her problems were caused
by Satan and and today it was a best way
to avoid your problems being caused by
Satan is stopped believing in Satan yes
and so like I witness would abdicate
your own responsibilities of like well I
can't control this so my fault it's st.
the devil's doing it right the death and
he was writing this letter to the Pope
and in the story and and like blaming
like Satan and like all of a sudden lady
just brought back these these feelings
of I remember when I was 21 and my mom
was in County Jail and I was like
visiting her on my 21st birthday and it
was a strangest thing because like like
somehow she was ever like it it was it
was the oddest scene like I could see
this in a in a movie because she said I
got the guards to convince the guards to
like get some helium inflated balloons
for me for my 21st birthday so I show up
to the county jail my mom's doing a 60
or 90 day stint for a DUI oh wow
and the guard hands me I'm holding these
helium balloons I multi-color 21
balloons and I had to walk up to the
glass to pick up the phone to have this
conversation while mom I 21st birthday
hand
and Yoshi so burnt out cuz she's behind
behind the glass there and it brought
back all these sort of memories and
there are and I have closure on it now
but in in my waking hours but I don't
dream that much whenever I have dreams
they tend to be nightmares and they're
almost almost exclusively about my
mother and and this book this is what
good fiction does it it brings out the
the emotions that maybe we didn't want
to deal with yeah help in a way way it
was cathartic it helped me deal with
some of those emotions it brought me
back to that place um I forgot about
being there on my 21st birthday holding
these ridiculous balloons in the Warren
County Correctional I don't know who had
a worst growing up man
no I sometimes I think no I was more
dysfunctional III I mean it's weird like
I mean you got beat a lot more than I
did
so yeah so I don't know but um
you know it's funny man like just going
back to the like getting over this this
this relationship that I have had a
funeral for I've talked to some friends
and I have this one friend in particular
who if I let them go on they they could
go on for an hour about how you're so
great and you don't deserve this and
you're such a lovable guy and people and
and and those are very kind words mmm
like I appreciate it but in the same
token like I don't feel like a victim
like I am NOT I'm not living up to the
victim role right and one that we talked
earlier about the victor versus victim
yeah and yes I you I you could look at
my situation your situation and say you
were the victim and instead I look at it
like I can't believe I got out of that
yeah yeah last week we were talking
about that drag so on the elevat-- song
and like I couldn't imagine like when I
was there and getting over to this side
I may I feel like the Victoire like yeah
man I I you know it's like when when
LeBron dragged a bunch of subpar subpar
players to the finals and in 26
actually drag them to winning the final
yeah and you realize like I feel like
I've done the same thing I'm the LeBron
of my own life right getting past those
circumstances yeah man yeah and that's
yeah that's exactly what I'm getting at
man is like I think you and I instead of
you know cuz it's easy it is easy to
fall into the victim role but instead of
using that as a source of discontent and
allowing you know negativity or
discontent or even drama into our lives
like we take what has happened to us
and yes like coming through the other
side is so much better than playing
victim yeah like owning up to having not
control because you know I never feel
like I'm fully in control but I am fully
in control of my decisions and like that
to me and making good decisions living a
good life like that is that's the best
way to kind of overcome all those all
those you know times that we were
victims of of our families yeah even if
you are a victim of something I was a
victim of a hit-and-run mmm last year we
were on tour we were in Dayton Ohio I
was in a rental car and I was on feed
wire road and what was that moment in'
pike yeah I was driving in this truck
just sideswipe I mean I don't know if he
was a huge truck I don't even know that
he sideswiped me and like totally like
ripped the bumper off it was crazy and
you know startled me for sure mm-hm and
I saw oh my god I can't believe happened
but also oh my god like it could be
worse and and I made it out of this
that's okay and I have to have to deal
with the insurance I have to pay the
deductible cuz we did have a copy guy
and the police couldn't find him but
guess what it could have been worse and
and I out of everything I've been able
to overcome
yeah I'm sure there'll be other things I
have to overcome - yeah he's something
terrible that will happen at some point
and I need to be able to overcome that
it makes me sad man when I see certain
people I love family members or friends
who they get stuck in and playing the
victim role it's a lot of the times it's
easier to play victim it is easier to
say oh my life isn't good because I'm a
victim of this situation so the rest
my life all of the problems that I have
it's due to this one it's easy to like
point the finger and connect Heather
everything back to that that that past
sort of influenced yeah and some some
folks who live in this state of being a
victim they wouldn't know what to do
they're scared of not being a victim
yeah they wouldn't know what to do if
they actually had to take some
responsibility for their own life and
yeah just reiterating taking
responsibility feels so much better than
playing the role of a victim last year I
did something with the rubberband thing
that I'm sure you've probably those 21
days without complaining I think it's
like a Tim Ferriss thing yeah
but I tried it out and like you can't be
the victim if you never complain right
right and so either we got to the point
if I didn't even complain out loud
oh god this is can't believe I'm stuck
in track whatever like after a while
after the the Pavlovian response yeah
all of a sudden it was like even in my
head if I had to complaint in my head I
would snap myself yeah and then the
complaint started going away in my own
head because I was reprogramming myself
in a way and so if you want to avoid the
victim role I think quite often it
starts with stopping the complaining
yeah and it's easy to stop once you
become aware that I'm complaining all
the time yeah some people I mean maybe
learn is you know I'm not trying to
undermine people who were in situations
right now but to get through it and yes
like reprogram how we we view how we
were victimized yes it's it's it's just
a much better way to to deal with people
who were in obstinance to your life yeah
and the way I would sum this up
basically is yes you might be a victim
you may have been a victim but you don't
have to keep being a victim in fact you
have to stop feeling like the victim to
eventually become the victor yeah uh I'm
gonna recommend we recommended this
probably within the first twenty
podcasts maybe thirty but uh the app
every dollar so I finally downloaded
this app uh-huh and started using it
okay it is a it's Dave Ramsey's app that
he has to help budget mm-hmm and Mariah
and I well after like because I've been
reading Rachel Cruz's book and Chris
Hogan's and Anthony Anthony O'Neal and
preparing for the tour
yes I talked about this in the last
podcast about if you have money problems
but don't have a budget then don't
complain about your money problems
right because budget is step one to not
having money problems yes and it has it
has just really inspired me to redo Ryan
eyes budget I mean we did a budget years
ago but what Chris Hogan in his book
retire inspired he said he said you
should have a I'm paraphrasing here you
should have like a financial meeting
once a month with with you and your
partner even you and your family that
the household the government doesn't
even do that and like looking at the
government as as the example is like a
really that's a really bad way to to
like view our finances it's a great
example of what not unnecessary spending
right yeah exactly so so you know what
when I when I was hearing that line I'm
like wait a minute Mariah and I haven't
talked about our our budget for years
like we just kind of came up with a
budget and we moved to LA like okay it's
gonna cost us this much more but it's
very it's very loosely based so yeah
downloading every dollar and like
actually planning out every single
dollar that we're spending I think this
is what reason this is great is we
talked about I having a budget to get
out of debt and that budget your budget
you had really helped you get out of
that yeah my budget helped me get that
what you're talking about going beyond I
even being out of that you know I've
been out of debt for at least half a
decade yeah and still sticking to a
budget helps you what are they
eliminates the falls
I wanted yeah does I want to be the best
saver that I can be yeah when it comes
to my finances like I want like the
retire inspired book I mean it's really
motivating to it's good motivation to
help you really have a plan for your
retirement and I think you know I would
do okay but looking at my finances after
you know reading these books
I am I realized that I could do much
better yeah so yeah we downloaded every
dollar and dude it is awesome like you
can you can literally put in every
single line Adam it's super intuitive I
mean it took me a second to kind of
figure out how it worked but it is a
free budgeting app and it has made the
world of difference and dude it has done
thing
like like I will we were walking the
other day to dodgeball and I wanted to
like stop and just grab like a water or
sparkling water at the convenience store
yeah and I was like if I do that I'm
gonna have to like get out my phone and
put that expenditure in my in my
budgeting app and we have a we have a
bottle of water right here that we
brought with us I don't really need this
sparkling water but it like totally it
just helps you it just changes your
perspective on how you spend money
because it is just so easy but I only
spend two bucks here I'm gonna spend
three bucks there I'm gonna spend two
bucks here well if you have to type that
into an app every single time you spend
two or three bucks
not realizing a lot of his junk exactly
yeah absolutely
all right let's move on to right here
right now so we talk about what's going
on in the lives of the minimalist where
I talk about dodgeball we already talked
about Drake at least once on this
episode once or twice on this episode so
we'll stop oh we're hiring a filmmaker
so the reason we're doing a three camera
setup here and the Matt is here today is
we had about 50 people nearly 50 people
apply for round one for this the
minimalist it's our favorite game show
the minimalists are hiring a filmmaker
and we narrowed it down to 19 people for
round two they submitted they answered a
bunch of questions and they submitted
and we sat down as a team this this
weekend me you and Sean and Jess
remotely but then we also got we would
never lay down to seven people and then
we got feedback from Matt and and Jeff
and Dave who do our web development and
design and Jessica gave us some
additional feedback backs gave us some
feedback and we got this top seven down
to a top four and have moved them on to
a third round now yeah so if four people
shout out to Katie Alejandro Devon and
Jordan you know I hate to say the cliche
thing I wish we could hire them all but
it's so yes yes like it's it is just
unbelievable talent that we have we have
had apply and it's it truly is a hard
decision like I really wish we could
hire them all and really good people a
lot of personality there's a lot of
great humor a lot of talent a lot of
skill and a lot of unexpected things
through the whole process where you you
start to pick up these little nuances
about these people in their lives and
what they're doing with
creativity and a lot of people are just
really striving they're done with
content generation and they want to
produce meaningful creations and we're
seeing more and more then that was a
commonality between everyone who who
especially everyone who made it the
second round like you could tell these
people really wanted to do something
meaningful with their creativity and so
stay tuned we're gonna figure that out
we're gonna have all four of those folks
edit this episode and then we'll we'll
figure out where we go from here
the next round will be meeting with some
folks and then we'll go from there also
if you were looking for some questions
about sex and look we're gonna have dr.
Christopher Ryan on the podcast later
this month awesome and so questions
about sex if you have questions about
sex then give us a call also about love
we're gonna have Peter Rollins dr. Peter
Rollins I mean I guess technically he's
PhD right so he's a doctor Peter Rollins
be on the podcast you and with his
beautiful beautiful Irish accent can't
wait to talk to him also questions about
business jobs and sleep we're trying to
line up some guests for those as well so
if you have questions about sex love
business jobs or sleep give us a call
for a four zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine we'd love to hear your
questions also this weekend we're headed
out on tour we're going to Kentucky with
Chris Hogan retire inspired and some
other folks from Dave Ramsey's team
we're gonna be in Tennessee Nashville
Tennessee will be with Rachael Cruz Dave
Ramsey's daughter she wrote a book
called love your life not theirs and
then in Alabama we're gonna be with
Anthony O'Neill he has the five mistakes
you can't afford to make his book we're
talking about money and minimalism and
the cool thing about this tour it's
called the simply southern tour you can
find tickets over the minimalists calm
Tennessee is Nashville that's almost
sold out we saw have some tickets left
in Kentucky and Alabama and probably few
tickets left in Tennessee a hundred
percent of the profits from this tour go
to help build this grocery co-op that
we're trying to build so folks will
remember on my birthday my 37th birthday
ask people to donate thirty seven
dollars
sort of buy me a tie clip or a necktie
or any other thing to put around get you
both I donated and I got you a tie club
did you give me a gift receipt of course
thank you so so I what we're trying to
do is bring food to one of largest food
deserts in the country our hometown
Dayton Ohio on the west side has one of
the largest food deserts in the country
second hungriest city for families in
the countries Dayton Ohio we want to
change that by giving people their
families their access to food by
building the first grocery store on the
west side since 2008 or 2009 when Kroger
closed yeah so there is not there's
access to food but not real food there
you can get cheetos that you're the
corner liquor store burritos yes but a
fast food of course yeah there are some
fast food options there aren't real food
options when you give people some real
food options they're also some education
you can help us out with that you can
come to any of our simply southern tour
stops in Louisville or Nashville or
Birmingham Alabama the minimalists com
for tickets or you can just go to the
minimalists comm slash Dayton and you
can donate 37 bucks on our birthday if
you can't afford that donate 5 bucks $2
whatever you can afford help us bring
food to people who really need it
there's a few new writings on our
website the 3030 rule I alluded to it a
little bit last week if you're gonna
check out the 3030 rule for minimalism
and something that's really helped me
out and I solidified that rule recently
I think you'll find some value in that
also 5 questions to ask before buying
something is on our website plus there
are 600 other free essays on our website
so you can dig into the archives there
as well over at the minimalists com our
new book have you seen the cover to it
you know there's no copies I don't know
what we'll find it afterward but
minimalism our old book yeah for our
first book is now in German so I think
it's in a dozen languages now roughly
and the German cover is my favorite
cover out of all the covers that they've
done so far awesome also check it out
sure there's something on Instagram
where it's posted something yeah I'm
sure I'm sure they have I think we have
a few around here we put them out on the
bookshelf in the common area as well but
the German cover is my absolute fave
so it is available in Germany for those
of you listen to this we are a top 100
podcast in Germany so I know we have a
bunch of German listeners also we're
working on a new documentary with our
friend Matt dia Vella it's called the
minimalist less is now and I think we
have three scenes left the film it's on
right we just finished all the voiceover
so close so close and and then we're
gonna work on the soundtrack we're gonna
have Shawn just break out his drums and
do heavy drumming throughout the entire
do we are friends yes so the folks who
did the first soundtrack they've agreed
to at least give it a shot on on this
new one Andrew and Nate from they they
formed a band called we vve can check it
out the the first minimalism soundtrack
wherever you get music also if you want
the show notes each and every one of our
podcast episodes we always reference
these show notes just go to the
minimalists comm but your email address
at the top will send you these show
notes directly to your inbox whenever we
put out a new episode and if you want to
comment on this episode or any other
podcast episode you can leave your
comments over on youtube in fact new
episodes come out on mondays now a day
before this podcast hits your audio feed
so you can check those out over at
youtube.com slash the minimalists ryan
you got anything else for us speaking of
comments I got some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners check them
out hi this is Chantal and calling from
Montreal Canada I'm calling in regards
Josh mentioned that when he moved he end
up noticing that he had a lot of
cleaning products I make my own cleaning
products basically they consist of water
sometimes vinegar alcohol and essential
oils there's many many recipes out there
they're very efficient and we always
have those products in our house and
they save us a lot of money and time so
and there is also clean my space which
is terrific
YouTube channel and she has a book as
well where she has a lot of recipe for
cleaning various surfaces how to clean
in an efficient matter and cleaning with
various products as well like fiber
cloth so hope this helps thank you very
much bye bye hi this is Lauren from Los
Angeles Josh and Ryan welcome to my city
I have some advice for Georgia about
letting go of baby things Georgia if
you're on Facebook search for a local
moms group in your area I found a great
one where moms buy sell and give away
tons of items after their kids have
outgrown them it felt really good to
give my baby things away to fellow moms
who can use them and then they'll pass
it along to the next mom it's also a fun
way to make new friends
in your neighborhood nowadays whenever I
need something for my daughter I check
to see if anyone is selling or giving
away that item on the group before I buy
it new if you do have a second baby you
can get whatever you need from the same
group I think the second time around I'd
realize that you don't actually need a
lot of stuff to care for a newborn of
course there's a billion dollar industry
telling first-time parents otherwise
even though I'm a hardcore minimalist I
did keep a few baby clothes for
sentimental reasons
I'm currently sewing them into a quilt
for my daughter
I've embroidered her name and birthdate
on it and it'll be a sweet little
memento for her someday or just a cozy
blankie for nap time now if you don't
sew or quilt and that's something you'd
like to do there are plenty of sewers
you can hire to make a quilt for you out
of your favorite little baby things
check out check them out on FB or
Instagram anyway that's it thanks for
all you do guys bye hi there this is Amy
from Oakland and I listen to your
podcast about social media and I have a
suggestion that's helped me my weakness
is Facebook and the thing that
it's most difficult for me is when I go
on Facebook I see the newsfeed in my
face and I start scrolling through the
newsfeed so I actually found an app that
eliminates the Facebook newsfeed and you
download this app and it's called Claire
I'm not sure how to pronounce it but
it's spelled CL AR you download it and
then after that when you go on Facebook
you don't even see the newsfeed anymore
so you can just use Facebook for private
messages or search for you know what
your friends are up to if you need to
but that newsfeed is not right there in
your face when you go on Facebook so
it's less distracting really really
helpful for me but there are other apps
out there as well if you look up
newsfeed or rat Eradicator z' for
facebook and they work for other things
like other social media like Instagram
as well but it's something to think
about because for me it worked
helpful and I spend less time on
Facebook and less distractions alright
thank you
alright y'all that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for 0 6 2 1 9
7 8 3 9 you can also email a voice memo
from your phone to podcast at the
minimalists comm we're especially
looking for those questions remember sex
love business jobs and sleep that's
really what life's about Ryan alright
yeah well that's our new it's our new
pillars with the 5 values job business
and sleep a few of these don't actually
belong here yeah so 5 different future
episodes but you can ask us a question
about anything right we're okay with
that whenever your question is you can
call up and leave it but we'll put you
to the front of the pile there if you
have a question about any of those five
areas and if you all leave here with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works well thanks for
listen y'all we'll see you next time
and minimalists